AIDS of Nevada also known as a fan
returns with their 36th annual black and
white party and here to tell us more
about the festivities we have Andrew
Ryan Andrew he brought the Sparkles I'm
so excited to have you here thanks for
being here thank you thank you for
having us so before we talk about the
party let's talk about the cause tell us
a little bit about a fan a fan eight for
AIDS of Nevada we are the largest and
oldest HIV AIDS service organization in
the state of Nevada we've been
established in 1984 providing services
for HIV AIDS in Las Vegas and Southern
Nevada wow well you guys do incredible
work in the community and this party
everyone waits for it every year so I
see we have some special guests over
there I think we got to bring them in to
talk about the party what do you think
definitely you know the black and white
party is all about the fashion you can
wear as much black and white as you want
or as little as you can get away with
and I encourage people to get creative
yeah but you'll see everything in a sea
of black and white and the costumes
really become part of the Party part of
the decor and that's what makes this
party so exciting is you know you get to
let your your imagination run wild and
you show up and you're black in your way
and there's food and drinks and
entertainment you guys have a huge
lineup of entertainers as well right we
do and food and beverage we have seven
restaurants five liquor vendors and an
incredible lineup 12 acts from up and
down the Las Vegas Strip all coming
together to support afan for one night
only at virgin Hotel wow well I am
distracted because I see the most
amazing costumes behind you should we
bring in our models yes I would like to
bring out one of our performers doing a
special set that night Chase Brown Chase
Brown welcome look at this look Chase
Brown is coming to us from his
incredible show downtown at the
notoriety theater called Vegas country I
love it is a great show and I couldn't
wait to have him back he's what we like
to call a veteran of the black and white
party he's performed with us before and
he's going to come back and do something
brand new that nobody's ever seen and of
course it's going to be looking amazing
yes he's got Sparkles too so I'm loving
both of you guys all right for our grand
finale who do we have over here we have
Rosa Rosa looking amazing are these
balloons
they are our friends over at Balloons
with a Twist and Michelle did another
fantastic job every single year they
bring things that I can even imagine how
they think of these things this is
incredible but balloons with the twist
turns it out every year they're one of
our major sponsors of this event we
couldn't do it without them and Michelle
actually you'll see her in red this year
Michelle Rothstein is a balloon a
balloon to the twist is a right to wear
red honoree so you'll see our honorees
wearing red so if you see somebody in
red at the black and white party that
means they are a special person that has
helped their organization and we're
honoring them this year oh my gosh
congratulations and shout out to
Michelle she's one of my dear friends
and so deserving so really quickly where
can people get tickets and it's
happening October 22nd right yes afan
lb.org you'll have information all about
Athen you can learn about our services
you can get your tickets there we still
have tables available which is a great
thing to do because you get a place to
sit and you get to help out Akon that
much more well you guys thank you for
being here trust me when I say this is a
party you don't want to miss so we all
need to strike a pose thank you guys the
36th annual afan black and white party
Returns on on October 22nd at virgin
hotels for tickets you can visit that
website on your screen
afanlv.org Mercedes I'll send it over to
you